Speaker 1: Let's go next to I
don't know how to say this is it,
Saki Kazi from California. Am I pronouncing
that even approximately, correctly?
Speaker 2: And now what's all right.
Speaker 1: What's the right pronunciation?
Speaker 2: I go, Well, my name is it's
an it's a shorter our nickname. I go by,
it's like Sy Nido Saki until you
use Nancy as an taichi or something.
Speaker 1: Saki Kasi is that right?
Speaker 2: Yes. That's why I insist about that.
Speaker 1: Do you know how to pronounce
it? I guess. Let's start there.
Speaker 2: I want to go like. So then
she goes, you know, like the tall son and
she has in tights or something.
Speaker 1: All right. Well,
what's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Well, first I want
to say courage. I on your child. Thank you.
I want to know. So I assume you're saying
now and I'm like, oh, boy, sir. Yes, sir.
Speaker 1: So you're you're connection is
going almost like like lo fi. So did you have a
question just because I want to make sure I get
to it before we potentially get disconnected?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. The question.
Yes. Do you think that the Republicans, if they
were to take over the House, do you deny ever
trying to make America, the US or the United
States kind of like a dictatorship country? Like
like like what is the country
now? North Korea, in a way.
Speaker 1: No, they would not be able to install
a dictator. So as horrible as it will be if
Republicans take over the House and or Senate,
they will obstruct Joe Biden. They will say
horrible things. They will continue to encourage
political violence. They're going to do all of
those things. But they will not, at least in the
next two years, turn the U.S. into a dictatorship.
Speaker 2: Lynne Cheney Because like I remember
when Trump was still president at the time,
it felt like it was going to be attached
to a dictatorship. Well, to me anyway.
Speaker 1: No, no, no. I mean, listen, if you
have the president, the House and the Senate,
then it's a little bit different.
Speaker 2: I say, okay.
Speaker 1: Saatchi Kasi. I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly from California. I really
appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: It's an
honor to talk with you. I'm a big fan.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much. Very much.
Appreciate it. Let's take a very quick break.
Don't hang up. Don't hang up unless you're just
mad at me. But please stay on the line because
we're going right back to the phones in a moment.